a las vegas pioneer has passed away
siegfried fishbacher from zigfried and
roy lost his battle with pancreatic
cancer
he was 81 years old the death comes less
than a year after
roy horn passed away christian cazares
has a look back at the famous
magician's legacy on and off the strip
[Music]
siegfried fitchbacher was magical he was
flamboyant
he was also part of an iconic duo legend
in las vegas
broken heart and then the age i couldn't
believe he looked so good for his age
you know um but there was such a class
about the show that they did and the
stories
the memories that the fans have are just
so spectacular
born and raised in germany fitchbacher
was also drawn to magic
he met roy horn in the 1950s and
together developed an act on a cruise
ship
that catapulted the duo in the 80s to
become headliners in las vegas at the
new frontier
their show gained popularity in the 90s
with the move to the mirage
their magic show included live tigers
and elephants which captivated millions
year after year remember they had a
passion you know i remember growing up
you know hearing about them and
their passion for the tigers and the
animals and the relationship with them
but the career came to a stop with a
tiger attack in 2003 during a show
where roy almost lost his life the show
ended
but the stars continued to shine opening
two animal habitats
a dedicated park and a street on the
strip with both of their names
it's a las vegas icon so it's sad you
know like
it's one of the main characters in las
vegas so it's hard to hear about it they
brought so much to
las vegas with the shows and
opened a lot of doors for i mean look if
you look around now look at all the
at these acts that we have there is no
doubt the larger than life entertainers
loved las vegas for giving them so much
over the years
in may of last year roy passed away at
the age of 75
after contracting covet 19 and instantly
the love from his fans was felt
now those same fans are mourning the end
of a las vegas legacy
well funeral services will be private
now we know that reaction is pouring
from all over
including one local headliner david
copperfield
on facebook he said he is a pioneer
who together with roy illuminated las
vegas with illusion
christian casadas 8 news now